good
[Music]
hello today is thursday june 18th
3 gonzález greets you with his brief
information from news nao in spanish
an employee of the kitchen of the
mayfair club inside the bellagio tested positive for
the hobbit 19 in always shorts he said that
this was confirmed yesterday in  in the afternoon the
restaurant closed for the night the area
was disinfected and the staff works
to respect social distance in addition
anyone with symptoms can
be tested right there
and south of the las vegas script two
resorts will reopen their doors on the day of
today the paris hotel opened several restaurants to the public
and its swimming pool
will also be available like other
paris hotels has its
security measures plan in place to keep
visitors and work staff
safe employees will be checked before
starting their work shift  and they will wear
masks there will also be more faces
available for visitors and it is
advised that they wear them
here you can see that  more will reopen
today if supported yes vela gio
will open their poker rooms
from 10 am the wynn casino buffet
opens with some changes in its
agenda west gate also opens and top golf
in cuba will open its doors
now  we go through the weather forecast
we will have a dry climate with
some breezes from the northeast for today with
approximately 15 miles per hour
we will exceed 90 although this
temperature will be below normal
compared to the heat that is
approaching have a great day
cheers andrés  gonzález and this was
about news now in spanish
[Music]